- Well, I don't wanna say that because
that means I'm going to
- We're all in a long
march towards death, but.
- No, we are not.
(lively music)
- Hi, I'm Sam Stryker.
- And I'm Curly.
- And we're at the Film
Independent Spirit Awards
in Santa Monica, where
we're gonna ask celebrities
if they've had any
encounters with spirits.
We've been gravely disappointed.
We thought there were
going to be actual spirits
at the awards today.
- Oh, that's why you're
here, to protect us?
- Do you believe in ghosts?
We'll get right to it.
- Yeah, who doesn't.
- I'm dead inside.
I'm a total skeptic.
- Although sometimes I'm creeped out.
- I believe in ghosts, yeah.
- Have you ever had a
paranormal experience?
- No, but I'm really hopeful.
- Hundreds.
Thousands, probably.
- I mean, I've had moments
where I've been scared
where I'm like, "Mmm, I'm
not going down that hallway,"
because I just feel it's not
a good thing to do right now.
I'll do it tomorrow.
- Something kept changing the TV channel,
and I wasn't touching the remote.
- Netflix and chill,
but with like a ghost.
- Exactly.
There was no chill, zero chill.
- And I was walking past
and like in the corner
of my face like I saw
something like hanging.
- Was Sia hanging from the chandelier or?
- We love you, Cate.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Cate Blanchett just said we look fabulous.
Who would you come back and haunt?
- You, both of you.
- Yes.
- I would wanna haunt a descendant of mine
that I haven't met yet.
- Probably my kids.
- So like a happy haunt.
- Yeah, I'd happy haunt them.
- I wouldn't haunt, but
I would follow my exes
to see what they're up to.
- Yes.
- I would haunt DisneyLand so I could just
go on all the rides and I'd
get to skip all the lines.
- I don't need to die
to haunt Donald Trump.
I'd like to haunt Donald Trump
for the rest of his life.
- All right, guys, that was
the Independent Spirit Awards.
We didn't see any ghosts,
but we saw plenty of stars,
and Cate Blanchett said
we looked fabulous, so.
- She meant me, I think.
(upbeat music)